bonjour C'est latiti alidé et je vais
réagir aux archives de
Lina bonjour latitia alidé bonjour vous
êtes mannequin mais le public vous
connaît surtout pour avoir été pendant
23 ans l'amsœur de Johnny hidday et nous
vous recevons à l'occasion de
l'exposition Johnny hidday qui arrive à
Paris nous allons replonger dans cette
histoire la vôtre la sienne celle du
couple que vous formiez et tout de suite
nous commençons par un morceau qui a
longtemps été votre préféré
quand tes cheveux
s'étalent comme un soleil
d'été et que ton
oreiller ressemble au champ de Bré quand
l'ombre et la
lumière dessine sur ton cors des
montagnes des forêts
[Musique]
et que je
je connaissais pas cette version
elle est magnifique c'est difficile de
choisir une chanson ma chanson préférée
de Johnny il en a tellement mais
celle-là fait partie de mes chansons
préférées parce que il me l'a souvent
chanté alors le soir de votre mariage le
25 mars
1996 Johnny vous a fait monter sur scène
pour vous chanter une chanson l'hyne à
l'amour d'edit Piaf on va vous montrer
l'image
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur nous peut
s'éondrer et la terre qui peut bien
coulé peu
[Musique]
importe j'ai du
[Applaudissements]
mal c'est toujours très émouvant de
revoir ces images c'est le jour de notre
mariage on est on s'est marié le matin
déjà j'avais appris mon mariage une
semaine avant euh avant la cérémonie
Johny voulait que ce soit une surprise
puis finalement comme voilà comme
l'histoire de sa vie c'est très
compliqué de garder un secret et j'ai
j'avais découvert que j'allais me marier
dans la presse une semaine avant et on
s'est marié à nei le matin et puis le
soir on a pris l'avion parce qu' il
était en tourné
et dans l'après-midi on a on est arrivé
dans le sud de la France et je crois que
c'était à cor ou à Toulouse à Toulouse
tout à fait euh et je m'attendais pas du
tout à ce qui me à ce qui me demande de
monter sur scène j'avais gardé mon
bouquet de marié que j'ai jeté ce
soir-là aussi au public et et c'est la
première fois que je montais sur scène
donc j'étais j'étais très ému ça fait
partie des plus beaux jours de ma vie et
puis il m'a chanté cette chanson et
j'aurais voulu que le temps s'arrête et
revoir ses images et les revivre ça
m'aim toujours autant ça m'aim toujours
autant
c'est vrai que la légende Johnny a
commencé bien avant votre naissance nous
sommes en 1961 dans l'émission CQ
colonnes à la
une vous l'avez deviné c'est du rock
qu'il s'agit du rock hand drô comme
l'appellent encore ceux qui ne le
dansent
pas pour ces fidèles le Dieu de cette
religion nouvelle a un nom pour vous
encore barbare Johnny alibé le
voilà vous pouvez refuser de comprendre
d'où vient son succès
[Applaudissements]
mais vous ne pouvez nier qu'il possède
en tout cas une propriété quasi physique
quand il chante les corps des
spectateurs se tordent dans la salle
comme sous le feu de mil000
[Applaudissements]
soleil c'est ce qui est encore fou
aujourd'hui c'est que je continue
d'apprendre de lui de découvrir de lui
de ce que j'ai partagé avec lui mais de
ce que j'ai pas connu comment il a
emmené le rock and roll France comment
il est devenu Johnny Hidé il a eu
d'énormes critiques à l'époque on
comprenait pas sa musique le rock and
roll personne connaissait le rock and
roll en France voilà le voir avec sa
guitare avec son déhanché avec cette
attitude cette rock and roll attitude
qu'il avait déjà à l'époque quand il a
commencé il voulait être Elvis il
voulait être James Dean et il est devenu
johnnyalid ce qui m'a marqué c'est
cette cette volonté d'exister il a vécu
à 200 à l'heure il a vécu 1000 V
Johnny a toujours été assez fusionnel
avec ses fans on va écouter une
admiratrice parler de lui sur l'ORTF en
1968 je trouve que le fanatisme en
France peut exister que pour Johnny
alidday en France il y a que Johnny
enfin vraiment il a tout pour être une
idole je crois que
Johnny il vit plus sur
scène que dans la vie on voit aussitôt
qu'il rentre en scène où j'ai même moins
remarqué quand euh quand ça faisait un
certain moment qu'il avait pas chanté le
premier spectacle qu'il faisait après
vraiment là il était déchaîné on voit
qu'il adore ça vraiment que le petit
chanteur qui fait son son spectacle il
chante le nombre de chansons euh tout le
monde applaudit il revient parce que
c'est calculé mais Johnny si on
l'applaudit euh si ça marche il restera
le temps qu'il faut moi je l'ai vu déjà
resté 2hes sur scène il s'épuis
complètement je trouve ça formidable
ce qui est touchant c'est que j'ai j'ai
rencontré cette fan je l'ai très bien
connu parce que c'est une elle est
partie il y a quel il y a quelques
années elle s'appelle Josette c'est donc
une fan de Johnny au départ et elle le
suivait partout elle était à tous les
concerts devant le la scène et puis elle
a réussi à approcher Johnny moi quand je
suis arrivé en 95 j'ai connu Josette
Josette au fil du temps nous accompagnit
en tournée et était dans les backstag et
et c'est beau de la voir aujourd'hui de
laavir si jeune elle nous manque
aujourd'hui parce que elle connaissait
plus la vie de Johnny peut-être que que
lui-même c'était une archive vivante et
la mémoire de Johnny elle m'a beaucoup
aidé à retrouver des costumes qui sont
dans l'exposition aujourd'hui
elle a suivi des années 60 jusqu'à la
fin de sa vie elle est partie après lui
et je crois qu'elle est partie d'un
chagrin de de vivre sans Johnny sans son
idole c'est beau ce qu'elle dit c'est
touchant c'est c'est une vraie histoire
d'amour entre lui et son
public bah j'ai grandi avec les fans Mo
ils m'ont connu j'avais j'avais 19 ans
j'ai grandi avec eux au début ils ont eu
du mal à m'accepter et puis au fil du
temps j'ai trouvé ma place et encore
aujourd'hui cette histoire d'amour
continue avec les fans j'ai encore des
liens très fort avec beaucoup beaucoup
de d'entre eux alors latiti lidé vous
avez évoqué la différence d'âge écoutez
ce que les Français pensaient de cette
question en
1973 est-ce que vous pensez madame que
la différence d'âge dans un couple est
une chose importante ben oui et non ça
dépend ça dépend la maturité de l'esprit
de la personne non je ne pense pas
qu'elle soit très importante euh à
égalité ou plus jeune ou plus vieux il
n'y a pas d'importance pour vivre à deux
au même âge il faut énormément
d'imagination alors vous pensez avec une
différence d'âge importante pour une
femme enfin par rapport à moi c'est dire
plus âgé je me sentirais pas capable je
préférais que l'homme que je fréquente
soit plus âgé c'est plus réconfortant si
on peut dire on a plus confiance
peut-être bah je je vois pas l'utilité
que l'homme soit plus vieux que la femme
parce que il a déjà suffisamment
tendance à être paternaliste comme ça
c'est pas la peine de lui donner une
possibilité de plus de jouer les B papa
vous ne pourriez pas aimer quelqu'un de
très jeune non pourquoi parce que j'ai
besoin sécurité et j'ai l'impression que
quelqu'un de plus jeune ne pourrait pas
me donner cette sécurité mais quelqu'un
de trop âgé enfin qui est 15 à 20 ans de
plus ça me gênerait
aussi ça c'était dans les années 70 oui
oui ça tout à fait c en 73 alors on voit
que les avis divergent pas mal vous ça
vous a pas fait
peur non non ça m'a pas fait peur du
tout ça a fait peur peur à mon entourage
ENF ma famille mais moi non non parce
que parce que c'est la rencontre de deux
âmes aussi
euh deux âmes qui se rencontrent et qui
se sauvent et qui apprennent à à à
s'aimer
à c'est oh là là j'avais pas revu ces
images depuis depuis très très
longtemps c'est les images de votre
mariage votre mariage euh non ça m'a pas
fait peur mais je crois que c'était
un je Johnny était j'ai toujours pensé
qu'il était beaucoup plus jeune que moi
dans la tête moi j'étais une vieille
hâme et eu et c'est peut-être ça aussi
qui l'a rassuré mais je non j'ai pas eu
peur je puis j'ai j'ai mon papa vivait
avec quelqu'un de plus jeune que lui
aussi et euh et puis non c'est une ça a
été la chance de ma vie quoi de de vivre
avec quelqu'un de plus âgé
euh parce que j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai
j'ai énormément appris de de lui de la
vie de de ce qu'on s'est transmis tous
les deux nous allons maintenant parler
de votre rôle de mère vous avez adopté
deux petites filles Jade et Joy écoutter
ellisabeth Badinter parler de l'adoption
et de l'instinct maternel nous sommes
sur le plateau d'aujourd'hui madame en
1980 cette partie de la définition de
l'instinct traditionnel à
savoir une une impulsion à aimer ce qui
sort de soi est aujourd'hui démenti et
je suis convaincu en ce qui me concerne
que une femme ou un homme qui adopte un
enfant l'aime infiniment je dirais même
que c'est là un cas presque typique de
l'amour et de l'amour volontaire choisi
en ce sens que c'est il faut décider un
jour qu'on va chercher un enfant c'est
c'est vraiment un acte formidablement
choisi et je dire à la limite que même
la maîtrise de la fécondité actuelle
n'implique pas c même acte volontaire ce
vrai désir d'enfant alors ce que je peux
dire aussi c'est que quand vous parlez
vous d'instinct moi j'ai envie de parler
de désir comme le professeur Charvet don
le titre de son livre Ctait désir
d'enfant et moi j'ai envie de parler de
désir et pas du tout d'instinct c'est
c'est joliment dit je connaissais pas
cette interview
et ça met le père et la mère au même
niveau quand on quand on
adopte mais le désir il est là et
l'instinct c'est quand l'enfant est là
qu' on sent qu'on a un instinct maternel
mais mais le désir et la volonté d'être
parents dans l'adversité puisque c'est
un l'adoption c'est un long chemin c'est
pas que comme une naissance biologique
c'est un combat aussi c'est 10 années de
de stérilité de de de de d'un désir qui
vous pousse à
à vous remettre en question vous
réinventer aussi à travers euh ce désir
de de d'être parents oh là là ces images
elles sont tellement touchantes elles
sont tellement
bouversantes c'est la fin d'un long
chemin euh jusqu'au Vietnam mais mais
c'est c'est un désir et une volonté qui
est réfléchie
et moi j'ai pas pu donner un enfant
biologique à mon mari il il il en rêvé
de cet enfant j'ai j'ai pas pu lui lui
lui donner parce que c'était parce que
la vie a pas voulu que que je devienne
une maman que j'ai pas pu porter
d'enfant dans mon ventre mais mais
c'est ce chemin jusqu'à jade c'est
probablement la la plus belle chose qui
nous soit arrivée je pense pas que
j'aurais été la même mère enfin j'aurais
été une
mère j'aurais aimé mon enfant mais là
c'est la chair de mon âme c'est un désir
tellement euh qui vient de loin qui
c'est c'est le plus beau cadeau que la
vie nous ait donné l'arrivé de Jade a
tout réinventé dans notre notre vie elle
a réparé Johnny aussi à travers
l'abandon
effectivement Johnny a lui-même été
abandonné par son père il en a même fait
une chanson que nous allons écouter sur
l'émission CAD Rousell c'était en
[Musique]
1971 il y en a qui naiss dans les du
drapeau s désir Hyne militaire et quand
la troupe défile sous leur carreau il
sont l'ARM guerrière mais pas moi non
pas moi je suis le fil de
personne vivre avec un chanteur
abandonné c'était c'était pas facile au
quotidien mais mais en même temps il
avait tellement besoin d'être d'être
rassuré d'être materné Johnny et c'est
ce qui me plaisait aussi dans ma
relation avec lui c'est que j'ai
toujours aimé le materné toujours aimé
j'ai toujours essayé de
comprendre ce traumatisme de l'abandon
qu'il a accompagné toute sa vie la peur
de de d'être d'être abandonné
encore ce besoin de solitude aussi ce
besoin de se détruire pour renaître et
pour connaître la lumière ce besoin de
de de s'abîmer pour se
reconstruire mais l'abandon a été
toujours la accompagné toute sa vie
jusqu'à l'arrivée de de Jade qui était
elle aussi une enfant abandonné et il y
a eu un un avant et un après ça a été
vraiment un moment important pour que
Johnny puisse lui aussi pardonner à ses
propres parents puisse lui aussi
renaître à travers cette adoption
euh pardonner ce qui a été le
traumatisme de toute sa vie et rien na
jamais plus été pareil le pardon a été
si essentiel à sa vie on va l'écouter
évoquer cette période où ces moments où
il se faisait parfois du mal dans 7/ 7
en
1991 on commence par on commence par un
joint hein et puis on finit par autre
chose je veux dire c'était c'est c'est
comme les gens qui commencent au début à
boire un verre d'alcool et qui finissent
par la
euh non vous vous avez décidé
complètement d'arrêter de boire moi je
buvais pas mal par rapport à mon métier
par rapport à tout ça parce que c'est
vrai je fais un métier on est très
angoissé quuellement et c'est vrai qu'on
a l'impression que de boire un verre ou
boire de verre ça ça ça rassure un petit
peu ça donne ça donne une espèce de de
confiance en soi ce qui est faux ce qui
est faux ce qui est complètement faux
c'est une des raisons d'ailleurs pour
laquelle j'ai complètement arrêté de
boir et je me porte beaucoup mieux vous
préférez vous demander de temps en temps
si vous avez confiance en vous que avoir
une fausse impression de confiance
confiance en vous moi j'ai pas
absolument pas confiance en moi je n'ai
pas confiance en moi dans la vie j'ai
pas confiance en moi en tant qu'homme je
n'ai pas confiance en moi par rapport ce
que les gens peuvent penser de moi
mais mais je me suis aperçu d'une chose
c'est que l'alcool l'alcool c'est c'est
c'est c'est éphébère ça ça n'enlève pas
les les les les les angoisses qu'on peut
avoir soi-même donc autant ne pas le
faire vous l'avez aidé à se sortir
justement de ce côté destructeur oui il
m'a fallu beaucoup beaucoup de temps
avant d'y arriver parce que certaines
qu'il en avait besoin aussi
euh mais je connaissais pas non plus
cette interview qui est qui est très
touchante on sent la la ce que en fait
il est pas il est pas en paix parce que
ce manque de confiance en lui et en même
temps c'est comme ça qu'il était
l'artiste qu'il était j'ai toujours
essayé de de jamais juger aussi ces
moments où il avait besoin de se
détruire ce moment où il était cabossé
ces moments où il avit besoin aussi de
solitude eu et en les comprenant c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à aider quelqu'un
à aller mieux ne pas juger quand il se
fait du mal ou quand il se il s'abîme
mais plutôt essayer de l'accompagner et
d'avancer avec lui je l'ai aidé comme
j'ai pu c'est un homme en paix qui est
parti et ça c'est ma grande fierté il
m'a fallu des années mais mais je luii
je l'ai accompagné pour qu'il apprenne
enfin à s'aimer et à aimer les autres
parce que si on s'aime pas soi-même
c'est très difficile de de pouvoir aimer
les autres ou de pouvoir donner du temps
aux autres il a réussi à trouver la paix
l'adoption de Jad et Joy ont été
salutaire aussi dans ce chemin quand on
le voit sur scène et cetera on a
l'impression que c'est l'homme qui a le
plus confiance en Lui du monde ouais pas
du tout déjà il était tellement trackur
il était Johnny Ctait l'être le plus
trqueur que j'ai jamais connu monter sur
scène c'était il y a pas une fois où il
est où il est monté sur scène où il a
pas eu peur mais peur c'est-à-dire que
c'était des peurs où il était il était
dans sa loge et il avait il était pris
de nausée de vertigge de de
transpiration de après ça passait mais
les trois qure premières minutes c'était
très intense et puis retardit toujours
le moment où il allait sur scène ça
voilà ça c'était aussi renoué un Pact
avec ses démons et et C dém c'était
l'alcool et la drogue mais mais ça c'est
aussi comme ça qui puisait son
inspiration mais on a on a réussi à
combattre ces démons il m'a fallu
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et dans les
années 90 il a été une icône et comme
toutes les icônes qui ont été des icônes
dans les années 90 il a eu le droit à sa
marionnette dans Les guignoles de l'info
allez on
regarde bah qu'est-ce qui vous fait
rigoler comme ça johnny c'est c'est ce
truc là
qu tiens-toi bien pépéé tu vas rigoler
aussi bon ça ne fait pas de fumer au
moins ah que non que ça c'est une boîte
à coucou à C
coucou Johnny il aimait pas du tout
cette marionnette il en a beaucoup
souffert je crois qu'avec le temps il a
appris à vivre avec mais mais ça le
touchait beaucoup ça lui faisait
beaucoup de peine il il avait pas
beaucoup d'humour pour ça mais il était
très affecté puis et puis Laura aussi on
a beaucoup souffert parce que je sais
qu'à l'école elle avait des des
remarques dans la cour de récréation qui
a qui qui faisait beaucoup de mal à
Johnny ce qu'il aimait pas c'était cette
marionnette en particulier ou c'était
qu'on se moque de lui en général les
deux la le physique de la marionnette né
très très long ça lui plaisait pas et
puis il aimait pas qu'on le prenne pour
un idiot et là il avait l'impression
qu'on le prenait vraiment pour un con
comme il disait vraiment c'est c'est le
nez qui te dérange le plus je te propose
un
truc il il en souffrait beaucoup ça l'
affectait beaucoup la chanson Ma gueule
c'est un peu ça quoi ouais il répond aux
critiques
ma
gueule qu'estce qu'elle a ma
gueule quque chose qui va
pas revent pas c'est une belle réponse
c'est pour ça qu'il disait ouais il
répondait à sa manière sur scène c'est
la plus belle réponse mais mais ouais
non il a il a jamais eu beaucoup
d'humour avec les humoriste qui est
limité alors c'est pas seulement Johnny
qui a été moqué ce sont parfois aussi
ses enfants vos enfants
comme de nombreux enfants de star en
1998 louoyon témoignait sur France 2 de
cette difficile expérience les gens se
rendent pas compte à quel point ils sont
méchants quoi et PE ça allé je crois 5
si enfin je pétais la gueule aux enfants
de mon école enfin petit garçon manqué
parce que seul moyen de se défendre quoi
mais on vous attaquit pourquoi c'était
de la jalousie ou c'était
quoi toi tu es la fille de Jan Berkin tu
joues pas avec nous un jour ça va de
jours ça va et après toute sa scolarité
on commence à envie de verb quoi h c'est
ouais tu peux pas jouer avec eux et en
plus avec mon nom vu que je m'appelais
loup j'ai arrivéis dans la cour et il y
avait tous les élèves qui se cachaient
derrière les arbres on disant faut pas
qu'on l'approche c'est un loup elle va
nous manger en plus c'est la f Jen
Birkin et sa mère elle faisait des
photos de nu avant et cetera je te jure
et tout ça alors les enfants ils parlent
pas quand
dit ça c'était en 98 ça a pas trop
changé j'ai toujours le même problème
aujourd'hui ça abîme et moi mon rôle de
maman c'est de protéger mes enfants de
d'en parler avec elle oh par qu'elles
sont jolies mes
filles je parle beaucoup de du
harcèlement qu'elles vivent sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est tous les jours
elles reçoivent des menaces de mort le
harcèlement c'est au quotidien aussi
qu'on les j sur la façon de s'habiller
ou la façon de se tenir ou
de c'est dur parce que c'est pas les
connaître elles ont pas un papa qui
était ordinaire et nous avec Johnny on a
essayé de déjà à travers leur adoption
aussi de de partager cette différence
avec elle parce que on savait que à un
moment donné ellesre elles allaient être
victimes de
elles allaient recevoir des des des
critiques et des mots qui sont assez
violents qui sont assez cruels sur le
fait que ce soit pas des enfants
légitimes que ce soit pas du même sang
et on voulait vraiment les protéger et
qu'elles soi armé avec des mots pour que
plus tard elle soit en paix avec ça
alors nous allons évoquer maintenant un
sujet qui a fait polémique et qui a pu
tarnir l'image votre ancien mari nous
sommes sur France 2 en 2007 Johnny
exprimait le souhait de devenir belge il
évoquait les raison sentimentale son
père est natif de Belgique vous savez
que j'ai la moitié de mon cœur a
toujours été ici un hommage à ses
racines ou peut-être une simple étape
sur la route d'un paradis fiscal Monaco
pour échapper au fisque Johnny réside
déjà en Suisse hstat il doit y vivre au
moins 6 mois et un jour par an pour
payer 10 fois moins d'impôts qu'en
France 350000 € par an s'il devient
belge alors c'est le jackpot 2 ans de
patience et il pourra gagner Monaco ou
le sort d'un belge n'a rien à voir avec
celui d'un Français Suisse Belgique puis
Monaco une probable grande évasion
fiscale diversement appréciée dans les
couloirs de l'Assemblée c'est quand même
pour une bonne part les Français qui ont
contribué à sa fortune parce que c'est
quelqu'un de fortuné donc en quoi
serait-il insupportable lorsqu'on est
fortuné d'apporter une petite
contribution à la solidarité nationale
on n pas déménagé si souvent là ça fait
17 ans qu'on vit aux États-Unis qu'on
est résident et et citoyens
américains donc déjà les États-Unis ne
sont pas un paradis fiscal on est imposé
de la même manière qu'en France puis la
Belgique Johnny est à moitié belge par
son père euh puis la l'histoire de
Monaco je crois que c'était beaucoup d'a
faabulation parce que on a jamais eu
l'intention de vivre à
Monaco la vie de Johnny a toujours
déchaîné les passions a toujours suscité
beaucoup d'affabulation et en même temps
c'est c'était pas un être ordinaire et
c'était pas une vie ordinaire donc
c'était normal la Suisse on y a vécu
très peu de temps on y a passé 3 ans et
puis et puis on est parti aux États-Unis
mais l'histoire de de Johnny avec le
fisque français c'est
c'est c'est l'histoire de toute sa vie
c'est ça a commencé très très jeune ça
continue encore aujourd'hui alors autour
de de Johnny il y avait des des fans
mais il y avait aussi les amis
écoutez-le parler de son entourage dans
l'émission 5 colonnes à la une en
1966 copain çaexiste pas je trouve ce
qui existe c'est des amis le mot copain
tout le monde est copain dans la
rue quand les gens viennent me voir dans
la rue me disent
cinématographe catographe on est des
copains des gens qu'on connait pas c'est
copain est devenu un mot qui veut plus
rien dire avant ça veut dire quelque
chose maintenant ça veut plus rien dire
c'est c'est devenu commercial non ce qui
reste c'est les amis souvent c'est à
cause des gens tu vois qu' qu'on perd
des amis à cause de de genre des
Raconteurs tiens là m'a dit ça tiens
j'ai entendu dire que l'autre m'a dit ça
et puis on en finit plus surtout dans ce
métier c'est un métier de de Rago ah
c'est affreux et alors en
général tout se gâche comme ça aussi
bien les les copains que que les amours
que que
enfin c'est c'est c'est très difficile
ce métier pour ça
oui je suis d'accord et c'est c'était il
y a longtemps qu'il disait ça et ça a
pas trop changé souvent il avait un une
intuition qui était saisissante et moi
parfois je lu disais mais non tu te
trompes il il avait un il a finit par
avoir cet instinct dont il parle au fil
du temps il avait beaucoup plus de
clairevoyance dans la
rencontre évidemment qu'il y avait une
cour autour de lui et mais il était pas
Dupin il était pas DUP mais je crois
qu'il a beaucoup appris qu'il a beaucoup
grandi des
trahisons mais c'était pas quelqu'un qui
pardonnait
euh donc il il était très rancuné si on
le trahissait il avait d beaucoup
beaucoup de mal à pardonner et quand Jad
arrivé dans notre vie il a vraiment
voulu revenir à l'essentiel donc du coup
il a complètement réinventé notre vie on
est parti vivre aux États-Unis on a
petit à petit construit cette vie de
famille avec beaucoup moins de gens
autour de nous tout ce que me disait
Johnny de quand il était encore là euh
benah je l'ai compris quand il est parti
il avait raison il voulait me protéger
de certaines amitiés toxiques je le
voyais pas et et il est parti et je me
suis rendu compte compte de certaines
amitiés qui sont plus dans ma vie
aujourd'hui que je pensais qu' était des
amis et qui nous ont vraiment lâché les
filles et moi et il avait raison et
j'aurais dû l'écouter alors il y a la
famille mais il y a aussi l'amour en
2011 Johnny à l'idé expliquer à Claire
Chazal que vous lui aviez redonné le
goût à la vie et donc la force de
chanter j'étais dans une déprime totale
j'étais j'avais plus de goût à rien
j'avais plus de goût à la vie vous savez
quand quand j'étais dans
coma on dit qu'on entend des voix comme
ça ouais euh moi j'entendais le moi
j'entendais la voix de Laeticia ma femme
et très sincèrement je c'est sa voix qui
m'a donné le courage de revenir à la vie
c'est elle qui m'a qui m'a empêché de
sombrer j'aurais pu
sombrer je sortir du néant comme ça
c'est quelque chose ENF c'est une
expérience que je ne recommande à
personne notre vie a basculé en en 2009
euh après une opération compliquée il a
été plongé dans un coma pendant un mois
et ça a été un combat pour moi de le
sauver de l'accompagner je savais qu'il
m'entendait je parlais beaucoup à
Philippe Labau un ami à lui il a écrit
un livre qui s'appelle la traversée il a
entendu et ressenti des choses pendant
son coma et il me disait continue à lui
parler continue à à lui raconter des
choses continue à lui parler des enfants
continue à lui raconter le tout ce qui
se passe à à l'extérieur pendant qu'il
est plongé dans ce coma il t'entend il
ne cesse jamais de lui parler donc j'ai
pas quitté son sa chambre pendant un
mois et il s'est réveillé de ce coma il
est tombé en dépression il avait perdu
sa voix et ça a été un long long chemin
de dépression et de et de de de guerre
pour qu'il retrouve sa place dans la vie
pour qu'il reprenne confiance en lui ça
nous a pris des mois avant que qui
puisse se
sentir reconnecté avec sa propre vie
lorsque Johnny ALID est mort il a eu le
droit des funérailles nationales
réécoutons un morceau du discours
d'Emmanuel Macron en son hommage c'était
en décembre
2017 parce que Johnny était beaucoup
plus qu'un chanteur c'était la vie la
vie dans ce qu' là de souverain
d'éblouissant de généreux et c'était une
part de
nous-mêmes c'était une part de la
France que ce jeune Belge décidant de
prendre un nom de scène anglo-saxon soit
aller chercher très loin le blues de l'â
noire américaine le rock and roll de
nasheville pour le faire aimer aux
quatre coins du pays était hautement
improbable et
pourtant c'est un destin
français ça dép passe l'entendement son
histoire je je
savais que bah que je vivais avec un
être à part un être
extraordinaire avec ses pares d'ombrees
ses pares de de peur d'angoisse de de
traumatisme mais je savais que que je
vivais j'ai eu la chance de vivre avec
un un être comme lui il y en a il y en a
pas deux artiste et et homme comme lui
Johnny c'est lui tout seul c'était c'est
l'histoire de France et c'est une part
de la vie des Français une part de notre
histoire il a traversé tellement de
générations son enterrement son histoire
et ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
funérailles ça dépasse l'entendement
c'est un cri d'amour
[Musique]
extraordinaire
alors c'est le moment pour moi d'arrêter
de vous poser des questions et pour vous
de choisir qui va vous poser la
prochaine entre Denise Glazer Anne
Saint-Clair Jean-Louis servant schrebert
et Léon zitrô Anne Saintclair quand vous
regardez tout ça là comme ça qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que vous dites que vous
aviez du talent et que personne le
savait quand je je regarde ma vie je
j'ai je me dis waouh qu'est-ce que j'ai
eu la chance de de vivre cette vie et de
continuer à transmettre ce que j'ai
appris de Johnny mais ouais c'est c'est
je me sens béni d'avoir vécu cette
vie-là merci la vie merci de d'avoir
vécu avec un être comme lui merci
Laeticia lidé
[Musique]
merci